you're looking at Houston where the next
Democratic presidential debate will take
place one week from today the ten
candidates who made the cut include nine
politicians and Andrew yang the 44 year
old entrepreneur who made millions
running a test prep company had zero
political experience but his campaign
took off with his proposal to give every
American adult $12,000 a year his early
success has surprised almost everyone
except yang himself in a CBS this
morning broadcast exclusive for our road
to 20/20 series we met up with yang at
his rather spartan campaign headquarters
here in new york city this is national
headquarters yes yes this is it where
the magic happens this feels like a
pretty modest space from which to launch
a national campaign it was more modest
than this report this is actually you
like it madam feels plush on the walls
headlines chart the course of the
campaign when we started in early 2018
yeah I was a longer than long shot but
Andrew yang thrives on being
underestimated you actually thought you
could get somewhere with this well I was
apparently correct in the first two
debates you were given the least amount
of actual speaking time the opposite of
Donald Trump is an Asian man who likes
math you expect that to change this time
I do but after the last debate we raised
over a million dollars in the 48 hours
afterwards and so now I've developed a
reputation for making the most of
whatever time I get is more than 200,000
unique donors have given an average of
$25 apiece
many attracted to his blunt assessment
of America's future how do you feel
about the American dream the idea of it
I love it I lived it my family
immigrated to this country you still
believe in it well I'm a numbers guy and
so the numbers say that you have a 50-50
chance of doing better than your parents
if you're born in the 90s and that
chance was 93 percent if you were born
in the 40s or 50s so the American Dream
is dying by the numbers and
Americans know it yang's dark Outlook is
similar to president Trump's but he
blames the rise of AI and automation we
automated away four million
manufacturing jobs in Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and if those
states sound familiar those are all the
swing states that Donald Trump needed to
win and did win so to me this is a
straight automation story that
immigrants are being scapegoated for
economic problems they have little to
nothing to do with with it's not
immigration it's automation it's not
immigration it's automation and it will
lead to widespread despair he writes in
his book the war on normal people
creating a hyper stratified society like
something out of The Hunger Games some
advisors have said suggested to you you
should be more optimistic that's true
and I think most politicians have been
sold on the fact the American people
don't want to hear hard truths and I
think that's wrong they want to hear it
straight you think yeah they want
solutions not happy sound bites at this
point yang's solution the cornerstone of
his campaign is the freedom dividend
he'd pay every adult $1,000 a month no
strings attached and funded in part with
a 10% value-added tax on business
production the Tax Foundation which is a
conservative think-tank has run the
numbers and says basically they don't
think your math adds up that you
couldn't pay for a benefit that
significant with the funds that you're
talking about raising here they're
correct that it's not that the revenue
pays for it dollar for dollar but what
they overlook is that if you put this
money into Americans hands the money
doesn't disappear where does it go it
goes back into our consumer economy and
circulates over and over again the
argument is it would discourage people
from working would it make more sense to
guarantee people jobs like Bernie
Sanders is promising the first thing is
that there's no data that shows that us
getting $1,000 a month would reduce work
levels overall in terms of Bernie's
Federal jobs guarantee I understand the
spirit of it but in practice it would be
very very difficult to implement and
manage imagining that
all Americans want to work for the
federal government is something that
Bernie might think is in our minds but
that's not the case when I talk to most
Americans yang says he doubled his
campaign staff of about thirty last
month and will soon double it again if
for some reason you were not to get the
nomination would you consider it
you're laughing cordiality
would you consider a third-party
candidacy my job is to help yet Donald
Trump out of office and I would do
nothing that would increase the odds of
him sticking around and I think a third
party candidacy would do just that
Yang's candidacy of course is still a
longshot he's polling between two and
four percent nationwide and and lower
actually in the early states so he's got
a lot of work to do but he's put some
ideas on the table that most politicians
have not wanted to talk about one
involved very bold and he's betting that
Americans feel that things are not
getting better and want to hear about
that it's also interesting to see if
some of those ideas spark other ideas
within other candidates as we move
forward yeah I mean but he wants he
wants the idea of a unique I mean of a
universal income to actually become
policy he said he doesn't want it just
to be talked about he wants it to happen
you never heard anything like that but
we shall see